elle donne accès aux droits de vote et à
la liberté d'expression c'est la
citoyenneté
depuis le 8 septembre guyancourt lui
consacre une exposition un moyen de
raconter l'histoire de la ville au
travers de documents issus des archives
municipales et départementales
le thème des journées du patrimoine est
justement son sur la citoyenneté et
c'était vraiment l'opportunité d'une
rentrée rentrée scolaire bien sûr
rentrée culturelle aussi mais c'est
aussi rappelé les symboles les devoirs
les droits bien sûr d'eurasanté droit de
logements découpé en plusieurs
thématiques l'exposition évoque la
notion de citoyenneté les devoirs du
citoyen ou encore les symboles de la
république
une des pièces maîtresses à retrouver la
liste électorale de 1944 où figurent les
femmes pour la première fois inscription
des femmes sur les listes électorales et
l'accès au droit de vote pour les femmes
a été édictée par une ordonnance du
général de gaulle en 1944 et c'est à
partir de cette époque les femmes
acquièrent leur citoyenneté complète
finalement sur la cinquantaine de
documents présentés la majorité sont des
originaux
certains n'ont jamais été exposées ces
témoins du passé de la citoyenneté sont
à découvrir à l'hôtel de ville jusqu'au
1er octobre